Jennifer Archer's script is into the
deep blue
this is a story of heartache and hope as
it explores one man's struggle to
contend with the death of his mother
some trouble with the law
and a potential firing you Romance
unfortunately Jennifer is unable to join
us in person this evening but we have
this video to share with you
hi good evening and thank you for such a
lovely introduction
it is so humbling to be part of this
inspiring history that is the nickel
and to be in this incredible Fellowship
of writers
my writing Journey has been a lot like
my life
sometimes I love it
sometimes it's really hard
and there's always a lot of wondering
where is this going
and for me that's the part I've learned
to appreciate the most
the wondering
The Wonder of it all
I've been thinking a lot about my
grandfather lately
he was this quiet polish gentleman who
barely spoke a word of English but he
loved to watch me skate
and at the end of every competition
before the results were ever announced
he would grab me by my shoulders and say
you did it Jenna you did it
at the time
this was incredibly frustrating to me
because I knew mistakes were made and I
knew I certainly did not do it
and to see him beaming with pride
over what I perceived to be a certain
failure
felt
undeserving to me
it took many years
to truly understand his words
every time you challenge yourself
every time you put in the work
regardless of the outcome
every time you just get through the day
because these days that is enough
remember
that you did it
and tomorrow
you can do it again
I'd like to thank my family and friends
for their endless support and
encouragement especially my son Cole
he truly has all the good ideas
thank you to all of the early judges and
readers thank you to the incredible cast
bringing our words to life tonight
thank you to G and Don Nichol for the
gift of this Fellowship
to the academy members who reached out
to me in recent weeks I will forever
treasure your messages
and to the nickel committee
you believed in this story
these characters
and me as a writer
I am forever grateful for your support
thank you for handing me the Baton
this is something I can run with
thank you
[Music]